[Music]
hello everyone its Peter Brown reading
Heidi Kemp's review of Dragon Quest
eleven echoes of an elusive age the
Dragon Quest series is a standard-bearer
for an entire genre numerous JRPGs that
have come and gone over the years have
adapted from and built upon many of the
formulas Dragon Quest established in the
fitt era while series like Final Fantasy
have transformed dramatically over time
Dragon Quest tends towards
traditionalism keeping many of its core
gameplay and story concepts from game to
game Dragon Quest 11 is no exception the
chosen hero and his growing group of
party members go on a globe spanning
adventure in a realm of fantasy and
magic exploring dungeons solving story
beats to proceed and battling foes in
turn-based combat it's a tale you're
probably familiar with if you've played
any classic Japanese RPG but Dragon
Quest 11 is proof that traditions and
tropes don't have to feel worn-out and
dull as this gorgeous adventure will
challenge your skills tug at your
heartstrings and keep you eagerly
playing further and further into its
lengthy quest fishing for rumors huh
some things never change the hero of
Dragon Quest xi is a reincarnation of
the luminary a chosen hero who will
destroy a foretold dark presence yet the
glorious hero is not welcomed with open
arms when his destiny is revealed some
fear han is the harbinger that darkness
is soon to come wishing him dead as the
hero adventures from his hometown into
the wider world
he makes many friends and faces many
enemies encounters wicked monsters
endures intense tribulations and fights
for light in the shadow of an empire
manipulated by darkness that setup
likely sounds quite familiar the story
and Dragon Quest 11 doesn't really offer
any novel plot beats or twists but
that's not a knock against it the game
does a spectacular job of melding
familiar story elements with engaging
characters an excellent choreography for
example a tournament sequence is
something you see a lot of in Japanese
RPGs but the presentation
characterization and sprinkling of humor
present and Dragon Quest Elevens
tournament arc makes it truly memorable
hello candle penitence
this is no ordinary and national one
unforgettable sequence involves the hero
learning about his mysterious origins
and the land that he came from while
that sounds like nothing more than a
genre cliche the way it's presented here
is absolutely beautiful and
heart-wrenching the characterization of
the games various personalities helps a
lot in making the story in world as
engaging as it is every member of your
party has a well-developed unique
personality that accentuates their role
in the story for example one of the more
memorable party members is a flamboyant
entertainer named Silvan doe his
over-the-top mannerisms cheerful
attitude and combat prowess make him
stand out but you also get the sense
that the clown act might be lies
something buried in his past there are
plenty of fun and pcs you'll interact
with in the story as well such as a love
starved mermaid an eccentric Dean of an
elite girls prep school and a stunningly
incompetent Prince finally the villains
like the conflicted Sir Hendrik and the
cunning jasper present a constant threat
that pushes you ever forward
[Music]
special praise should be given to the
games of localization while it does
change quite a few characters and place
names from the Japanese version it does
a magnificent job of making the dialogue
and overall mood of the game feel warm
so full and inviting character
personalities in the flavor of various
regions of the world come through and
dialogue with interesting flourishes
like accents and spacing I feel for the
editor who had to write hundreds of
dialogue boxes for the character who
only speaks in haiku even the incidental
menu in combat text has a fun
light-hearted feel to it that simply
makes running through menus more lively
and when things get somber and serious
the writing changes to match knowing
full well what sort of tone needs to be
[Music]
trained quest 11 is a very linear game
you hit one story point solve whatever
problem you're facing be it defeating a
monster or collecting an item beating a
minigame or various combinations of
these things and then you venture out to
the next area where you're presented
with a new story beat slashing down mobs
of enemies along the way to build up
your characters levels you can go off
the beaten path a bit to complete sub
quests and explore optional areas but
most locales are completely locked off
until you hit a specific point in the
story and like the world Dragon Quest xi
Kombat is familiar and traditional but
presented in a charming and engaging way
that makes it feel anything but dated
characters and enemies take individual
turns based on their agility and you
choose what characters do by either
picking commands from a text-based menu
or setting the CPU to act based on
preset guidelines animations play out as
blows are exchanged and spells are cast
and every so often there's a funky
little twist to the fight that liven
things up such as characters achieving a
pepped up state that raises their
abilities and grants them access to
special attacks while there's a setting
in the options that allows you to
physically move characters during battle
rather than having them stand in a
stationary row it doesn't change the
combat significantly positioning doesn't
affect attacks and the fighting remains
strictly turned driven boss battles
aren't terribly common but the big
fights are truly trying challenging you
to make use of your learned spells and
skills against a foe that will utterly
wipe you out if you don't play
strategically
[Music]
despite Dragon Quest 11 s massive length
anywhere from 60 to over a hundred hours
depending on how you pace yourself and
how much extra content in questing you
do it rarely feels like it's dragging
its feet there's always a new place to
explore a new character to encounter or
a new threat to tackle just around every
story corner occasionally the game gets
a bit murky when it comes to telling you
where to go next
in particular a mid game sequence
involving looking for six magical orbs
winds up being very confusing but it
doesn't often keep you in one place or
dealing with one subplot for too long
you also won't have to grind if you're
smart about picking enemy fights and
giving up character skill points and if
you ever need a bit of a break you can
invest time in various minigames like
crafting items horse racing and a casino
with slots and poker among other games
[Music]
innovation in games has talked about a
lot but it's also great to see
traditional gameplay formulas that have
been around for decades presented
exceptionally well Dragon Quest 11 is
one of the best modern examples of this
it's beautiful presentation both visual
and story-wise combines with the tried
and true gameplay formula for a game
that's full of heart and soul once you
find yourself sucked into the world of
Dragon Quest 11 it's going to be very
hard to put down until you reach the
grand finale
[Music]